but now I'm 34 so I'm living my own life
so Baba this is the last you're ever
going to see me I live in Australia
now Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mjid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping a reward click
the link and donate what you
Canam brothers and sisters and dear
friends I came across with this video
and obviously I don't like to speak
about you know I don't want to get into
that individual especially F truth I
spoke about long time ago giving him the
ETC but I'll be honest with you I came
to the point where I'm I'm L getting
irritated really really upset because I
just believe and look I know he has his
OBS Etc but I have to be real with him
man I'm sorry man if I look if I I
really I care about you as a brother
okay you're a Muslim yeah I need to keep
it straight and to the point well let
I'll be honest with you yeah brother if
you're watching this look I'm not going
to you you've got all Yes Men around you
you got people don't give a damn about
you okay all right listen to me bro you
are disowning your family here's a video
clip of him disowning his family there's
clarification which I saw than good on
this video where he said that he did
that for a reason we'll come to that but
the point is the following bro to hear
your dad on the phone upset and saying
he loves you and do not leave us that's
not acceptable bro I don't give a damn
and then you are there let's just watch
the video for God's sake I'm just a bit
frustrated here's the video of fuzzy TR
this owning his family W this is a major
sin Ma and then after that what you do
is also Maj but we're going to come to
in a few things let's watch it for
ourself I know I'm just calling to tell
you you guys are never going to see me
again Baba last year when I crashed out
and I was in the hospital Hospital
instead of checking on me Muhammad
texted me to say Yousef just let you
know me and Mama are disowning you as
family members you are on your own every
time I've messed up baba Muhammad and
Mama cussed me out and let me realize it
anytime I did a Hollywood red carpet
$100 million contract anything
successful they didn't open their mouth
and I beg them I know longer need you
guys in my life I'm a Muslim you guys
you guys put me on this Earth baba but
now I'm 34 so I'm living my own life so
Baba this is the last you're ever going
to see me I live in Australia now the
house in San Diego I'm still paying for
I'm I need you to drop off muffin to Los
Angeles I'm giving away my dog muffin to
her babysitter you guys lost me Baba I'm
living my own life
now no Baba
no well you H you have to live without
me now baba mama and Muhammad Baba
Muhammad didn't Muhammad last year when
I was suicidal on your so you heard that
for yourself I mean number one to call
your family members and say you're
dising them you have no right to dis
anybody you have no right to dis read
the book by IMI when it comes to the
etiquette of being a father you should
not call your father uh by his name not
I'm saying you are just saying a few
things you do not walk in front of your
dad okay you don't call him by his name
you have UT respect for him Scholars
said it so much so that bro the money
that you own he owns yeah so much so
your parents Allah says in the Quran
that after you worship Allah that you
are obedient to your parents let me tell
you something F yeah you will never ever
find happiness in Disobedience to your
parents ever I'm telling you bro even if
you're someone that prays Salah if you
are someone that oppresses his family
members directly or indirectly I don't
care how it is and your family are on
edge with you you will never find
happiness fuzzy Your solution is Islam
the effort that you give to your
bodybuilding and make your body look
amazing whatever give that effort to
Islam give 20% of that effort to Islam
obedience to Allah you will find change
in your life Allah's promise is true
only in his remembrance do hearts find
peace if you forget his remembrance you
will have a depressed life this is H
I've lived to see it I put it to the
test and I've Liv to see it I've been a
Muslim for 11 years and it is the truth
true contentment comes with that I lived
a lifestyle maybe not as lavish as yours
or whatever nothing brought me happiness
and it will never would and I would
thinking to myself as a 35y old man if I
was to live that same lifestyle of
clubbing partying girls this that I
would handle myself today I is this the
life is this what I need to do prual
cycle of like a 35 you are 34 year
old you said 34 35 years old man yeah
you're saying I'm going to live my life
you've been living your life all this
time bro why you acting like your
family's been stopping you your family's
been stopping you doing what bro you
have been living your life so I don't
know what you're saying about oh I'm
going to live my life you have been
doing this and then you're ordering your
dad to go and drop your some puppy
whatever the hell is for that matter oh
drop it your Dad should be telling you
what to do not you telling your dad what
to do the Dynamics is very dangerous the
Dynamics is very dangerous you should be
giving utmost respect to your father and
I'm not saying you a respectful person
to your dad Etc but you have no damn
right to come and tell him I disown you
I'm going to be paying for this taking
my dog who are you to order your dad
well life we have forgotten we have out
of our minds the prophet wasallam said W
they have reached an old age you should
be looking after them may his face be
robbed in dust may his face be robbed in
dust and the prophet repeat the
statement three times it shows it some
Scholars will say it shows it can be a
major sin they may his face be robbed in
D they said who mess of Allah for the
one whose parents reach old age and he
does not care for them and you are there
distressing them he's on the phone
saying I can't live without you upset
and you're saying you have to let me
tell you something this is oppression
shame on you grow up you're 34 year old
man you should be serving them you
should be having kids you be serving
them not going around uh doing videos
this that Etc come on man how old are
you man you're 34 years old act your age
man act your age I'm going to tell you
as it is man and that's cuz I care about
you okay you might not like this oh I
don't care bro grow up man you're a 34
year old man what are you doing and then
in this other video Let's see for our
he's now giving clarification oh this is
what I man in my life is I don't get it
I'm very confused yo you know how I dis
on my family the other day well I just
flew I drove all the way to San Diego to
look at them in the eyes to show them
that their son's not crazy and then I
told them every single thing they did
since I was a child that hurt me and
then I told them how much I love them
and need them in my life and said I
don't want you to just be parents I need
you to be my best friend for once and
they said of course of course
yeah the only reason I publicly did what
I did on the phone with my dad is to
protect them I had fake allegations
against me my sister is a prominent
figure in this world world my brother's
a very reputable surgeon my other
brother is a pediatrician my parents
they're retired if I had the real
allegations against me of course I'm
going to disown them why so that my name
and my problems don't bring them down
I'm
an we respect that name I love you baba
I love you too look I'm happy that we
are with your father but what games are
you playing bro man I don't understand
you man what games are you playing man
what is this about bro one minute you're
this on next what games are you playing
man like seriously man what on Earth is
going on there's in another video he
mentioned that his um his dad always
told him you know like how much money do
you make or something that I mean if
that was a relationship I mean I'm just
going to speak generic I don't want to
be disrespectful to anybody yeah but as
parents if we teach our kids successes
and he talks about oh oh success when
most success time you guys were there
you think having $100 million contracts
and this is success bro this is not
success bro we don't measure success
based on that if success is that then
Pharaoh was the succcess who Allah loved
Pharaoh no he didn't it's not about
money whatever bro Success is Not based
on that your compass of success is
flawed your measure your yard stick is
flawed I mean what can I say as parents
we need to teach our children what true
success is Quran Islam your religion
sticking by the truth justice Salah
doing righteous Deeds this is Success
this is what should be chasing if we get
our kids and teach them about money
success what what profession you this
their measurement is going to be that
and what do you expect them to do you
are building a generation of failure
success Dynamics is what how much you
earn that's why the reason why we've got
our sisters M growing up I when a guy is
going to give 50,000 what you made out
of gold bro what are you some dusty
woman who doesn't even praise don't do
nothing and you want 50 Grand Mah for
you who's going to pay want P 50p Bro 50
P I won't give you what is the value
you're bringing and then you got men
brothers Mah even better sleeping around
drugs everything yes brother Mah I'm
going to give my daughter to you brother
I won't give you toenail yeah so this is
the generation we building wrong goals
wrong goals what can I say may Allah
subhana tala allow him to serve his
parents the way they deserve to be and
may Allah subh make us parents who bring
a new generation that will serve the
dean of Allah make Allah's cam the
highest not what do I drive what do I
wear how many times do I go on holiday
um let me measure how good my wife is
based on um this or that or let
me what is wrong with you man where's
the measurement of you know Quran Salah
relationship Allah where's those
measures they are left even family
members are doing this they've left it
now the measurement is not based on
let's see you know what's he doing for
my daughter or for my son what's it it's
all based on metrics of materialism what
can you say that's all I have to say
brother
sisters the prophet sallam said whoever
builds a Masjid for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala Allah will build for him
a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana tala tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atom weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
oh